[Music]
hey there river babes
I'm your Riverdale high repping host
Leonid Galera and welcome to the
Sweetwater secrets preview show for
episode 212 chapter 25 the wicked and
the divine I think that's my favorite
show title yet and I can tell you that
this week's episode of Riverdale is
going to be much more satisfying in some
ways and a lot more frustrating and
others sorry I can't share more but
you'll see what I mean when you tune in
and then we can discuss it all on our
after show now today I've got an
exclusive surprise for you Lily Ryan
Hart will be weighing in on her thoughts
on dark Betty in season 2 but first
let's take a look at your hisses and
kisses about chapter 24 The Wrestler
fortunate you do know wrestling's not
like a football basketball right now
almost all of you agreed with me that
the wrestler was not a favorite episode
but when I asked you all if you think
that Veronica is starting to manipulate
Archie there was quite a mix of comments
let's take a look Audrey artists said I
think that since her dad came back we're
starting to see what old Veronica was
like I mean stealing the pussycat seems
like a New York Veronica thing to do
Karma's a [ __ ] but on the flip side Joe
wrote sorry Leon but I'm gonna have to
disagree with you why would a Veronica
not want Archie to know anything about
her family business if she was
manipulating him she literally wants him
as far away as possible from any of that
horrible mess she spent the entire
episode supporting him she loves him
okay fair point girl in Riverdale fan
101 posted I think Veronica is starting
to manipulate Archie not cool not to
mention that she stole the Pussycats
from Josie which was a really low move
meanwhile Alisa Battisti no dropped this
bombshell saying to be fair if Archie
was cutting at me with that water hazard
of a sweat stain I wouldn't kiss him
either
you see a bit you're sweaty Heather
Leonard added hisses - not enough bug
head and I think Veronica's only got
back together with Archie as part of
Hiram's plan and I also think the bug
head are getting back together in the
next episode I can neither confirm nor
deny those bug had comments Heather but
as for my one and only kiss last week -
Cheryl you all seem to feel the same now
Rowe thatch commented totally agree with
the kiss - Cheryl blossom it's good
development to see her branching out
from the blossoms and Shoni is totally
going to be iconic I cannot wait and
Nelly the elegant which is amazing wrote
Leon you are the Shoni captain hun you
give me so much hope for this couple
well you guys I will gladly sale that
Shoney's ship with pride I think they
would be great together
why don't you come over here and say
that to my face homily queen of the bus
guards now another story line that you
guys had a lot to say about was chick
leading Betty into his dark web cam
sexcapades world now you all meet a lot
of really great points and here are a
couple of my favorites now miss
Riverdale typed kisses - the writers
depression and other mental illnesses
are sad in something serious they are
not sexy especially if the sick person
is a minor girl sorry if any language
mistakes I'm from Germany girl you did
great job
now Audrey Harper also weighed in on the
issue saying I think Betty being a cam
girl is so bad there are so many better
ways to deal with these things like
please Betty go to therapy and I don't
want her doing anything she's going to
regret also do how and Alice like not
care at all when Betty told Schick that
she hurts herself right in front of them
did they know this whole time and not
help her all right guys now those are
all really great points and I too would
really love to see buddy's mental health
be addressed in a constructive manner
and so does Lily Reinhardt now here's
what the Riverdale actors had to tell me
about how Betty is dealing with her
internal demons in season 2 I think
there's a lot of darkness and Betty and
you know we've kind of always teased in
season 1 like that she was dark Betty
and episode 3 was she had her wig and
everything but that was a little bit
camping like the campy over
dark Betty whereas in season two it's
more real and grounded and it's actually
coming from you know a very dark place
inside this girl so it's not something
that necessarily is and not that season
one was but we're not really poking fun
at her having like this alter ego and
she doesn't have an alter ego it's just
this girl has a lot of problem that's
deep down and that's where the darkness
stems from and that's kind of what we're
shining a light on and season two is
just her eternal anxiety her demons now
it's obvious that Lilly cares just as
much about Betty as the fans do and
she's doing an amazing job bringing
awareness to mental health throughout
the series but I'm curious to know your
guys thoughts on dark Betty
especially after you watched chapter 25
the wicked and the divine so be sure to
check back to Sweetwater secrets after
you watch that episode to tell me your
top hisses and kisses and they could be
featured on the next preview show now as
always guys thank you so much for tuning
in
you can always chat with me on Twitter
about all of your Riverdale theories and
be sure you're subscribed to e t--'s
youtube page so you never miss an
episode of sweet audio secrets
see you soon river babes
[Music]